here's a cloud tip for folks looking for
a go-to resource for simple and fun
beginner AI projects have you heard of
experiments with Google it's a web page
that showcases projects tools and
resources created using Chrome Android
AI AR and more if you navigate to the AI
experiments collection you'll find a
great list of projects that people have
built using Google technology that
include the directions and resources for
you to build it yourself today I'm
trying out this tiny sorter project it's
this DIY experiment connecting Arduino
and teachable machine want to make your
own tiny sorter click the link in our
description for resources on this
project and to browse the entire list of
collections featured in experiments with
Google